we've all of a sudden learned a lot
about that infamous Trump Tower meeting
involving a Russian lawyer named the
Natalia vessel Mnet's kaya Donald Trump
jr. was at the meeting Paul Manafort was
at the meeting Jared Kushner was at the
meeting and many others and by every
indication this was an attempt at
collusion between Donald Trump's
campaign and Russia there was a quid pro
quo discussed where there would be
potentially a reduction in sanctions
through the Magnitsky Act in exchange
for the damaging dirt on Hillary Clinton
that Natalia vasilevskaya
said that she would be able to provide
and over time we've debunked a lot of
the lies about this there was the lie
that Donald Trump jr. wasn't really
going into the meeting expecting dirt
the lie that the Russian lawyer wasn't
connected to the Russian government in
any way but only now have we really
learned about the testimony related to
that meeting because the Senate
Judiciary Committee in issuing a report
that they believe yes that there were
attempt by Russia to interfere with the
election in 2016 to help Donald Trump
also released 2,500 pages of testimony
and exhibits yesterday and it is now
clear beyond any doubt that Donald Trump
jr. wanted to collude with Russia and
the big takeaways are number one the
people at the meeting said that no dirt
about Hillary was actually provided at
the meeting we knew that already it was
promised to be delivered later very good
number two because of testimony from
Renaud achma Chen he's the Russian
American lobbyists who was at the
meeting he claimed that Donald Trump jr.
knew exactly what the meeting was about
and actually said early on during the
meeting quote I believe you have some
information for us so the idea that
Donald Trump jr. didn't think there was
going to be dirt didn't expect there to
be dirt is absolutely bogus we also read
about testimony from Rob Goldstone who
was involved in setting up this meeting
and he testified that Natalia vessel
Mnet's kaya did indeed lobbied on jr.
about those Russian sanctions known as
the Magnitsky Act and how those
sanctions should be lifted we were also
pre
riously told that Jared Kushner was only
at the meeting for a little bit of it
and then left Rob Goldstone testified
under oath that Jared Kushner stayed for
the entire meeting yet another possible
Jared Kushner lie and then we also
learned more about remember that quote
that has been attributed to Donald Trump
jr. where he was told about the
possibility of this dirt from Natalia
vessel nets kya and he said if it's
later in the summer I love it we now
have the full context of that email from
Donald Trump jr. which said thanks Rob I
appreciate that I am on the road at the
moment but perhaps I just speak to Ameen
first seems we have some time and if
it's what you say I love it
especially later in the summer could we
do a call first thing next week when I
am back that's not exactly the email and
the language used by someone who's not
really interested in the dirt and
doesn't really think that there would be
dirt that's the email of someone who
wants to as quickly as possible after he
returns from a trip get on the phone and
figure out when they might be able to
have the meeting with Natalia ves on
that's kaya we heard from Heather there
was a in the testimony that we saw
transcripts of there was a moment where
Heather Sawyer who's a counsel for Diane
Feinstein asked Donald Trump jr. what
did you mean that you loved it what did
you love and she went on and said did
you mean that you loved potentially
incriminating information on Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump jr. said yes he
was asked in testimony whether he told
Trump's senior about the meeting and he
says that he did not very difficult to
believe he also said that he didn't
think there was anything wrong with
meeting a Russian lawyer promising dirt
on Hillary Clinton ahead of the election
and he also said he couldn't remember
whether he discussed the entire thing
with his father and that starts to
become the trend I didn't do anything
wrong and I also don't remember and I
have a really hard time believing that
Donald Trump jr. just has no
recollection about whether he told
Donald Trump senior that he met with the
Russian lawyer promising dirt on the
opponent if he's lying about not
remembering he actually still can be
prosecuted
is this idea that floats around that if
you just say you don't remember you
can't be prosecuted because you're not
saying something one way or the other
you can actually be prosecuted for these
so-called intentional memory problems
very unlikely like I don't think Donald
Trump jr. is actually gonna get in
trouble for that but the gaps in his
memory are very very bizarre yeah like I
don't know how you would prove that he
did in fact remember correct but I think
it's pretty clear that Don Jr told his
dad about it because I think so it was
such a small organization in that
campaign and this meeting after all took
place at Trump Tower plus what was it
like a few days after the meeting was
planned Trump promised damaging
information on Hillary Clinton yeah a
national audience minutes after the
meeting took place
Trump was tweeting about those missing
33,000 emails so the timing of it is
even more suspect and we actually have a
bit a bit of transcript to put up on the
screen just another element here
Donald Trump jr. was asked according to
this document 25 minutes after the first
call ended related to this meeting
you made an outgoing call to that same
number but in between the two calls
there's another entry a call at 427 that
lasted four minutes from a blocked
number
between a means call to you at 404 and
your return called to him at 431 with
whom did you have a call Donald Trump
jr. saying I have no idea and of course
9 minutes later Donald Trump tweeting
for the first time about Hillary
Clinton's missing 33,000 emails so the
timing stinks the lack of memory from
Don Jr absolutely stinks and these
transcripts raise even more questions
the intent to collude and again it's not
a legal term that is a colloquial term
which can include a couple of different
crimes potentially the intent to collude
is abundantly crystal clear and we only
have more questions and even fewer
answers as a result of these transcripts
which we will obviously continue to
follow and see how they play into Robert
Muller's investigation send me your
thoughts what do you make of the
transcripts I'm on twitter at d pakman
show is on twitter at david pakman show
today's program is made possible in part
by Warby Parker eyeglasses which I now
have two pairs of Warby Parker offers a
free five day in-home trial of their
glasses you try five pairs you see which
like I wear contact lenses on the show
but I often wear glasses at night and on
weekends and both of my pairs of Warby
Parker glasses are great I did the free
at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time to figure out
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker there start at just ninety
five dollars that's what mine costs to
try the five pairs and support the David
Pakman show
go to war V Parker trial comm /t DPS